[Musique]
eh bien il a donné de l a donné deux
grosses d'infos laurie tellement galère
à trouver des sacs pour eux pour ninja
warriors et votre création et la douce
voix là et voyez vous même d'arrêter à
tf1 galère il faut trouver des stars
partout puisque danse avec les stars il
appelle tout le monde non ouais enfin
bon bah oui oui j'ai paalga que je
rencontre dans la rue qui ne dit pas on
l'appelait pour danse avec les stars
tout le monde mais les montants change
cyril peuvent alors il vous aura plu
oui mais moi panneaux qui s'appelle tout
le monde mais moi pour 2 euros c'était à
votre liste et le bre stars qu'ils ont
rappelé yves rocher un chèque énorme au
début et pendant cinq ans ils m'ont
proposé l'émission
au départ c'était une somme laisse
tomber jeter quoi genre je sais plus ce
sens qu'ils sont mis à part deux ans et
rien sur 1000 roubles sentir trop tard
c'est sûr qu'ils se côtoient me suis dit
jean bart
chaque année y retirer 100 1000 kw et
donc j'ai fait la dernière année comme
la sison moins fort mais voilà pas été
payés à l'apéritif et voilà non sans
bill vous avez toujours dit non si wayne
et pour ça rien de ma main sur moi mais
on parle d'eux et là ça oui oui a beau
tout ça ouais non pas auxerre il avait
dit je n'étais pas allé par forme il
bon va très bien mais banon mais les a
écoutés au neutre mais c'est une torture
il faut quand même qu'ils soient
rémunérés de manière de manière
conséquente
il yad'autres torture il ya des gens qui
will wright et métiers qui sont beaucoup
voilà mes opinions aux profs vous voulez
dire
mine de rien c'est vrai que c'est une
émission qui nous attend et après les
mines et restes et votre ressource
sacrément voilà y ait des chars comme
une somme énorme parce que vous et pour
vous qui rappelle ici somilo ici autour
d'apple par laisser ces baleines ils le
feront chez 20 ans mais voilà merci jean
luc lemoine arrêté pour vous avez parlé
ça va ophélie modem comme ça vous dit
les choses ça va ça va on entre nous
trois trucs ce soir des produits de
l'érable danse avec les stars c'est une
tannée
vendredi on a un gros zizi
pas dit que ça avait dit aussi qu'un des
deux jumeaux à noël était un petit peu
db je prendre cher demain allez on y va
aller ces questions ouais mais l'envolée
une base idéale on y va bonjour je
m'appelle delphine on dit que pour
paraître plus beau il faut toujours
s'entourer de moosch
donc je voulais savoir est-ce que c'est
comme ça que cyril hanouna choisi ses
chroniqueurs sait pas faire que les
cowboys les premiers matchs sont
vraiment offensé dray ne venez pas là
dessus c'est une bonne question des
films et non série n'a besoin d'aucun
artifice splendide s'il est de plus en
plus beau il le doit qu'à lui-même et à
une hygiène de vie parfaite de bon et de
sodas et au contraire même il a
tellement confiance en lui qui n'hésite
pas à recruter dans ses chroniqueurs
d'une vrai séducteur comme cette année
vous le savez un grand séducteur j'en ai
plusieurs médias notamment benjamin
castaldi abri qui avec son expérience de
la chose amoureuse peut même donner des
conseils nos invités comme ici paga des
marseillais pourquoi tu fais tout ça
c'est sûr mais excusez moi si tu aime
quelqu'un et croire en quoi on croit moi
j'ai divorcé quatre fois et croire en
quoi on croit moi j'ai divorcé quatre
fois voilà grâce à paga aurore la
quatrième femme de vingt mois vient de
découvrir qu'elle était divorcée
[Rires]
mélange appelé les jours iront peut pas
être au four et au moulin
j'adore le sénateur a baissé le son moi
qui suis une brêle niveau drague ça fait
des semaines que je les observe pour
voir comment faire ce qu'il faut dire
aux filles pour les intéresser les
charmer et franchement là j'ai pris lui
aussi dans le cas grâce y allez-vous
tenter de dissocier un gentil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
mon village à l'écart
vous les femmes
[Musique]
c'est benjamin buts sur balles qu'aucun
des deux côtés des mots mais assez bref
que du lourd
en fait pas je m'occupe de toit après
l'autre caractéristique de benjamin
c'est d'être le chroniqueur le plus soul
et de la bande ils se saoulent fois rien
mais ça se voit que les gars c'est ça
soit 10 km
à sa décharge il est soit 1,6 à côtés
d'isabelle morini-bosc il ya des blagues
vintage que personne ne comprend mais ce
qui est bien c'est tu veux une de ces
belles ne passe pas bah elle insiste
c'était aussi le jour de la venue de
paga nous connaissent à 40 ans dans la
vie et c'est vrai qu'ils connais pas
gaston de la table présenter le connais
bien monsieur les lignes ennemies
[Musique]
c'est cette histoire avec votre votre
compagne on va arriver on va y revenir
vous allez voir même lui
voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du coup le problème c'est comme elle est
très pointu niveau humour quand c'est
trop simple elle argué là on parlait des
goûts musicaux de françois fillon
et je ne sais pas si vous souhaitez
c'est la première fois que mathieu était
assis à côté d'elle belle découverte
pour notre comité se décolorer à côté
tout ce qui lui arrive c'est un peu
normal qu'ils aiment police il faut
répéter toutes les balles attention ça
votre avis alors
[Applaudissements]
les
jean ça m'a rendu vers d'un sympathique
ton fils et j'ai eu la cote est parti
merci oui il est méchant ce que tous ces
méchants ce matin en disant qu'il parle
tout seul ghania gnagnagna c'est faux
enfin bon on est pêché voulu vérifier je
suis obligé de dire la vérité qu'on y
arrive pas toujours à prend la parole il
avait là en effet tendance a commenté
coup dans ton coin vous allez voir pour
le plus grand bonheur de ses voisins et
ce changement d'heure qui vous fait un
changement de vie vraiment moi non mais
je sais pas pour vous autour de la table
je voulais en parler mais moi je me suis
je suis revigoré et pas bien l'oeil le
changement d'heure j'ai envie de toute
la journée devait jouer au tennis
d'aller faire une pétanque thapa magar
mais sur lesquels tu as vu ce changement
d'heure elle va falloir vous avez tous
eu mois il brassera dimanche soir quand
il a eu qu'un amateur il encore jours a
maintenant soit quantité nuit
quant à coup trop d'histoires le
lendemain quand tu es enfant tu sais que
ta rendez vous avec la drh à la loire
j'étais plus jeune ça m'angoissait
encore plus parce que ma mère disait
d'aller me coucher il faisait encore
jour
soto week end à renard 2 mois
cet acteur un truc hyper jean raison
finalement par les commentaires du zabel
en même temps je suis venu lui faire
confiance qui s'était battue et il a
toujours raison
les quelques défauts mais on peut au
moins lui accorder d'être franc et
direct
par exemple avant qu'un invité offrez
des cadeaux vous avez rien apporté tous
les deux non c'est mal vous faire voir
parce qu'avant il attendait qu'on pense
à lui ou bien demander du bout des
lèvres me suffit dit tout ça maintenant
il a pris la confiance mathieu d'aller
voir ce qui se passe quand il n'y a pas
100 cadeaux direct nous recevions passi
et stomy bugzy jamais ça m'empêche pas
d'être un mec sympathique
ces projets
m
[Musique]
bah
j'ai les mains dans les poches et
rencontres
tel bar ne compare pas si on perd à
votre phrase de la techique mais je m'en
veux parce que j'aime pas quand
j'utilise la force comme ça ça deuxième
c'est pour vous moucher
ah oui tu veux pas donner je n'ai pas vu
habile et son fils mathieu les mais je
vais le féliciter car il s'est bien
calmée sur ces mytho avec cyril vous
rappeler l'autre fois la série
d'histoires et ben il ya eu franchement
un avant et un après cette séquence avec
tt mais vous allez voir la différence je
montrais une séquence juste avant que je
dis fils est gagé séquencé ce qui s'est
passé quelques jours après on va voir
s'il a évolué
[Musique]
sujet mathieu s'était aggravé la marque
est collé j'ai dragué par quelqu'un que
nous venons
moi non plus
4 il ya sept ans
[Applaudissements]
brady raconte qu'il a eu une histoire
avec mais c'est vrai qu'à ce thème dis
ça a changé quand même
il a choisi c'était une fiction la
caméra cachée tu sais non mais c'est en
ça ça s'appelle gaffe
bon je vous montre quand même le reste
de la salle garonnais bien c'est marrant
là c'est marrant ça va ça passe c'est
benjamin ça passe ou ça passe
bonjour je me convoquer la plage ou pas
après c'est vrai par butelle fin
d'émission
j'ai montré la suite et la séquence mais
juste pour la régression de cyril qui
est magique
ce que vous allez voir mathieu va
prendre un peu trop son patron pour son
pote qui va pas du tout apprécié le coup
de pression de la semaine
[Rires]
[Musique]
on fait pas ça remet pas cela peut
partir mais ça va car contrairement aux
autres chroniqueurs et bain mathieu ne
craint pas son patron
l'idée peut-être pas peur de syrie aux
non non non uns et les autres ils sont
flip est face à cyril mais nous oui
maintenant comme il l'expliquait d'aspe
gamme il ya quelques semaines à valérie
écoutez bien ça parce que ça ça va
vraiment vous plaire mais j'adore la
pour la station se régale à paris
jamais
donc
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais mes enfants ils avanthier dos
c'était pas un combat parce qu'en fait
c'est vous qui n'aviez raccroché au nez
mais j'aimerais quand même une déco il a
raccroché tu l'as trouvé des douze comme
ça c'est ouf et bella et mac os et gamal
à mon coeur l'effrontée quand même un
peu inférieur lundi mathieu a dit
quelque chose qui a beaucoup choqué
attendant que dans the voice tout était
truqué sur le choix des chansons
on revoit les images il est bien évident
constitution du queens tu as beaucoup
plus de chances de faire en sorte que
les gens se retournent que c'est du
chant du patrick sébastien joly chanson
fera plus facilement se retourner que le
géant vert c'est donc patrick g matinal
à ces robots inspecté patrick soit
vanessa débat pour laisser l'eau couler
dans le moule
oui je le connais il était colère cyril
a un qu'on puisse affirmer qu'on pouvait
pas gagner ce voice on chante en duo
patrick sébastien mari à la blesser moi
j'ai ma place et je comprends mais j'ai
une bonne nouvelle
et j'ai un scoop mais encore plus fort
que celui de maxifoot à l'heure je peux
d'ores et déjà vous affirmer que
matthieu delormeau jean michel mr
capucines à 909 carrière et caroline
ithurbide ne gagneront pas eu vol cette
année elle bat dès samedi en suisse ah
ouais
jo
[Musique]
à
un conte sais pas comment l'elysée parce
que normalement je refais toutes les
captations sur scène jean michel maire
et jean michel n'est pas là cette
semaine parce que il s'est fait faire
une opération vous allez voir mais on a
des chirurgies esthétiques vous verrez
il arrive je crois il faudrait serge pas
ce qui va revenir lundi
lundi sera de retour vers et et vous
verrez le changement c'est frappant oui
mais vraiment frappant pour la sale
impression que la frappe échoue et
[Rires]
calicots vallée retour ce soir là leur
camille puisqu'ils n'étaient pas là
lundi mardi il avait des petits
problèmes d'yeux alors oui alors
toulouse pour la boîte de nuit parce que
j'ai deux immeubles
m6 est pas là vous connaissez la livre
où il est charlie regardez ça un cv ya
une foule est au milieu de cette foule
il faut entrer un garçon avec un pull
rayé ouais bien se lance aujourd'hui une
nouvelle collection plus modernes ou et
mokhtar ces mêmes principes
je vous montre une image de foule vous
devez deviner où se trouve mokhtar et
comme il a un physique assez discret
activateur on vient aussi miraculeux
rayer ces parties 1
[Musique]
alors où est oktar regardez bien
l'attitude des gars de la bande y en a
10 d'après vous où est-il un aller la
réponse tout de suite en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et l'autre ils étaient encore torse nu à
dépouiller c'est bizarre des soupes
christophe carrière mokhtar sa belle
équipe de ouidah heureusement cyril a
recruté maxime gainey a oui à notre
fierté pour mon frigo notre fierté
maxime pour le situer ses négatifs de
benjamin castaldi lui demande pas s'il a
des crottes de nez qui pendent of n'ont
pensé durant les femmes
il fait appel à leur intelligence à avec
un certain succès mais vous allez les
filles sont sous le charme
c'est flagrant
oh l'amour il faut tourner la roue peut
dans le niveau des yeux de roger
les yeux
c'est le soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partage des connaissances et 8 façons je
vous le dis il veut qu n 2 a lui non
mais sans déconner c'est un phénomène
mais c'est pas con ski et j'avais jamais
remarqué la maladie c'est le même qui
était là mais si je te peut donner un
conseil faites vous dirais surtout avec
les équipes issia honnêtement tu devrais
faire un tour chez les castaldi ils
savent parler aux femmes
la vendée u la chance d'avoir deux
générations de castel dit le papa de
benjamin découvrez agathe a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'attenté du père jaloux qui est peut se
retrouver dans un instant mais quand
vous vous c'est parce qu'on va la voir
la séquence avec agathe regarder
[Musique]
jean racine c'est que vous regardez
beaucoup d'émissions vous êtes d'accord
avec moi j'aurais castaldi catherine
vous aimez bien gastal est pas là ce
soir c'est qu'on lui ai dit tout à
l'heure dans un pub oui c'est ça avec
pour ça merci seigneur c'est bush avait
pas meilleure transition faut aborder
tout ce qu'on est pas voulu voir et
entendre dans l'émission et on commence
par jean michel maire qui est pas là
mais en tout cas il y en a marre de la
présentation qui fait de lui à chaque
fois eric votre chauffeur de salle
[Applaudissements]
le monde
pagani
je
il y aura de la danse
il y aura du média il y aura de l'adar
cas il y aura zéro hora sera là quelles
qualités faut-il avoir pour être
chroniqueur dans votre émission et
surtout faut-il vraiment avoir des
qualités
[Applaudissements]
j'ai maintenant une très grosse tête
d
[Musique]
ce fut dur
mawazine jeu c'est nous ou les capteurs
le gifler une claque
[Applaudissements]
bravo merci vous y